time to talk about some fill in the
blanks let's get started the guests
you're most looking forward to having on
set next week in miami chris is who well
i mean it wasn't he wasn't on the the
graphic there and i hope that he hasn't
canceled but
of course it's kirk cousins
i mean i want kirk cousins to be there
that's gonna be amazing you're a vikings
fan
and we've had some moments of razzing
and we've had some moments of you saying
he's as good as patrick mahomes this
year there's so many good moments we
could talk about with kirk i feel like
he's part of the family that's who i
want to see more than anything
should i wear my curtains i think so
i think you need to bring it make sure
you pack it away you got to have it but
but in all seriousness other than him i
am excited to meet tua you know just
from like my scouting purposes just to
eye him up a little bit get a feel for
the guy that's gonna be a franchise
quarterback here if it weren't for kirk
cousins i would go with tua
yeah i i think kirk is going to be an
interesting time and and i i think he
gets it i think he's got some
self-awareness and i think he recognizes
it's an opportunity to have some fun and
i will remind him
i got destroyed with like uh 18 eggs
yeah that was in his best right so yeah
oh it was extremely disgusting so you're
going with cousins there though is that
the one you're most yeah absolutely
absolutely good but it's a great list
and again it keeps getting better and
better all the time uh uh once more
notwithstanding our involvement in the
program so somebody's doing something
right ezekiel had said change can be
hard but also good for the cowboys mike
mccarthy becoming the head coach in
dallas is blank for ezekiel elliott is a
great thing for ezekiel elliott i mean i
think it's the proper kick in the butt i
should say i think he needs it you know
one you heard me complain about ezekiel
a lot this year i don't think he was one
of the three or four or maybe even five
best running backs in the sport there
was a lot of yards there to be uh to be
that were left on the field on a weekly
basis to me he's got to get like to me
the legs don't look the same like he's
got to get training and squatting and
sprinting again and doing those things
and hopefully a guy like a new head
coach in a new regime coming to town
will light that fire underneath him
because what happens with a regime
change that didn't draft you and isn't
all in on oh my gosh ezekiel elliott's
our top five pick and he's the greatest
thing we have because he's our guy and
we love him and all that you got a new
head coach coming in he's gonna he's
just gonna it's gonna be a clean slate
yeah he's gonna know how good you are
okay but he's gonna evaluate it from
what you look like now to going into the
future and if things are kind of like
the way they looked last year mike
mccarthy then that's how those
conversations start up oh you know you
know zeke's not as explosive as i
thought he was and you know zeke uh he
missed a lot of big holes in this game
and whatever and that starts the decline
of you being a part of that franchise so
i hope zeke takes us the right way i
think it'll be a great thing for him
yeah and i'm intrigued by it because one
of the criticisms of mike mccarthy when
he was with the packers is he didn't run
the ball enough but did he ever have a
running back that he could run the ball
with i mean at times he did eddie lacy
the offensive rookie of the year in 2013
had 1178 yards he had 1100 yards the
next year and then he fell off and i
don't think he fell off because mccarthy
decided to quit running the ball he fell
off because he fell off he ate himself
exactly yeah and mike mccarthy has a guy
in ezekiel elliott who may be the best
running back and probably is the best
running back mccarthy's ever had on his
roster so now we see what what he can do
and how extensively he will use him so i
i think it's interesting i'm not ready
to say it's great for elliot because we
have to see that mccarthy is truly
willing to commit to the run run game
with zeke and last year what did we see
with the offense we saw a shift away
from it
and kellen moore's still there and
keller moore is calling the plays so
maybe we're going to see more of what we
saw in 2019 with ezekiel elliott being
used less and the passing game where
jack prescott nearly had 5 000 yards
being used more all right on wednesday
the raiders officially became wow the
las vegas raiders wow when you hear that
name blank is the first thing you think
of i think of john gruden in like a
white leather jumpsuit like al davis
with like diamond encrusted like leg
raiders emblem and like some al davis
glasses and like a gold chain and him
like just walking around with like the
zip up a little farther down right just
to show a little chest right there a
little few hairs of johnny gruden that's
what i picture i picture john truden
live in the las vegas lifestyle why i
think that i don't know but when i hear
las vegas raiders that's what i think of
i am intrigued by the whole thing i
think it's going to be really cool we're
going to have a team there the stadium
looks amazing but you want to know what
the first thing i think of is i think of
john gruden in the las vegas attire
that's what i think of
yeah i think you painted the picture of
elliot gold in ocean's eleven yeah right
that's what i'm looking at that's what i
mean or al davis like just take al
davis's clothes he wore the last 10
years he was alive and put them on john
gruden
you know what i first think of i first
think of tony romo because it was just a
few years ago that tony romo was going
to host a fantasy football convention in
las vegas not at a casino but at a hotel
at a convention center that happened to
be owned by a casino and the nfl shut
that bleep down in a heartbeat leaning
on players leaning on nfl media
employees who had signed contracts to go
appear at this thing these were all
allegations from the litigation that
happened but the nfl wanted nothing to
do with las vegas in 2013 there was talk
of preseason games or a pro bowl in las
vegas the league's position was we're
not going to do anything with las vegas
because of legalized gambling now here
we are there's a team in las vegas
they're having the draft in las vegas in
the fountains at the bellagio that's
where the red carpet's going to be they
got to take them out there by boat right
there's going to be super bowls in las
vegas not one it's going to be part of
the rotation right it's amazing to me in
the grand scheme of things in the blink
of an eye the nfl has gone from shunning
las vegas to embracing it with open arms
and also with the open wallets of
everyone who will be there for
every raiders game every super bowl
every draft everything they can do to
milk as much cash as possible out of
this las vegas connection and there's
nothing wrong with that it's just
stunning to see how quickly it changes
do you think i i never really thought of
this do you think the nfl thought about
the fact that gambling is going to
become legalized and then that opened
the owner's eyes to moving a team there
more do you think that helped move or
help them vote to say yes to vegas do
you think that was a factor or just pure
money and that's all there is to it
i think the nfl was confident that one
way or the other
states were going to be authorized to
adopt legalized wagering on sports one
by one and we're seeing it proliferate
now and if it hadn't worked through
litigation in the supreme court where
the nfl actually opposed right the
effort to expand legalized gambling they
were against it i'd never seen anyone
win so much by losing in the supreme
court in my lifetime they fought and
scratched and clawed against any state
legalizing sports betting and now that
the cat's out of the bag hey we may as
well embrace it yeah right and i think
if it didn't happen through the courts
it was going to happen through congress
where they were going to change the law
that prevented the states from adopting
legalized sports betting but i think
they knew look times had changed the
world had changed and there weren't a
whole lot of viable places for the
raiders to go they weren't going to
wedge them in san antonio between the
cowboys and the texans once los angeles
filled up with the rams and the chargers
they had to find someplace else for the
raiders and las vegas just kind of
became it because that all happened
before the law change that has allowed
sports betting to become really up
something that's part of the fabric now
of of daily life for a lot of people the
stigma is gone and the las vegas stigma
is definitely gone for the nfl all right
robert kraft told tmz this week that the
patriots plan to bring back tom brady
when bill belichick hears about that he
will be blank expecting that i mean you
know what first off tom brady's been
telling us he's going to play till he's
45 so belichick's probably prepared that
he's going to play and uh also hey the
new england patriots are the new england
patriots because of the connection
within that organization the front
office being on the same page as the
head coach and the coaching staff well
one is because the front office is the
head coach that helps but mr kraft and
bill belichick yeah i'm sure they've
butted heads before here and there but
for the whole they know how to
communicate and they're on the same page
about everything and i'm sure this has
been well thought out talked about bill
belichick i'm sure knows where robert
kraft wants to go with this whole
situation and vice versa and added to
the fact with josh mcdaniels not getting
one of the five vacancies open for head
coaching job as soon as he stayed in new
england i thought that really increased
the chances of brady staying there so uh
this is a tough one too because with
brady's comments last weekend i don't
you know what he does sound like he's
willing to go somewhere else if he has
to i really thought that you know when
all said and done he would kind of
buckle and kind of go oh i don't want to
play anywhere but new england but you
know from the the things he's been
saying he he seems like hey yes he's got
to leave town he's willing to do it
yeah and just to answer the question my
position is bill belichick will be
completely unaffected by anything that
is said by anyone about tom brady and
here's my prediction as to how this is
going to happen if tom brady does leave
i was talking about this last hour and i
think it may have come up yesterday as
well i think what we will see is a joint
statement from brady and the patriots
where both sides fall all over each
other to praise and to not be perceived
as the villain they want to be sure that
everyone takes the high road they don't
want the fans to pick sides that you
know they i think that that's the right
way to disengage and i think that's the
first domino in what will be a crazy
offseason of potential quarterback moves
if and when brady's out it'll be a joint
press release that comes up out of the
blue where tom brady and new england uh
patriots expressed their undying and
permanent love for each other but the
time has come for both sides to move in
a different direction doesn't that make
sense because they can't afford to have
this political jockeying for the hearts
and minds of patriots fans no no i mean
it does make sense if they do figure
that they're going to part ways i guess
the thing i'm interested in is and just
you know knowing new england and how
they operate what kind of money would
they offer brady if he does come back
what kind of money is brady willing to
you know take at this point of his
career
those are all things that i think are
really interesting about this situation
but yes if i think if they decide to
part ways you're right that's kind of
the way the way it'll go down
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports